this is how you make the wings are you
[ __ ] kidding me they're dry
how many weeks did you cook them for
they're [ __ ] disgusting there's me
thinking is a properly cooked [ __ ]
chicken wing this is the worst kitchen
in America hey what's up guys and
welcome back to hot ones you're probably
confused you are watching first week
feast but after watching mr. Ramsay tear
into the cold dry wings served on the
show Sean called me up and asked me to
make the wings for my own appearance
which is kind of like cleaning the gun
for your own execution but if we're
gonna do this we might as well do it
right so to keep the wings crispy and
moist on their journey from Soho to
midtown I decided to go with a low
temperature frying method that more
closely resembles confit first the wings
are fried at 225 degrees Fahrenheit for
about 20 minutes then removed allowed to
drain refrigerate it overnight and fry
it again this time at 400 degrees
Fahrenheit for 10 minutes this yields
the crispiest juiciest wings I've ever
tasted and they should stay that way
long after they've been doused and
poisonous sauce there we go two dozen
ultra crispy wings ready for transport
let's go see if I've got what it takes
to be a hot one
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even had her wings and
today we're joined by Andrew ray you
know him from his extremely popular
Cooking Channel binging with babish
where he whips up iconic dishes inspired
by TV and film he also has a new
cookbook on the way it's called binging
with babish 100 recipes recreated from
your favorite TV shows and movies with a
foreword from Jon Favreau and a blurb by
me andrew ray welcome to the show thanks
for having me mm typically we ask guests
how they handle their heat but I think
with you it's only fair that we ask is
there a TV or movie scene that involves
hot sauce that you think is the best of
all time not hot sauce per se but from
The Simpsons
Homer Simpson who tries to tangle with
something called the Guatemalan insanity
pepper which is a pepper that a scandal
I remember this oh yeah yeah so he
drinks a candle to protect his mouth
from the spicy stuff but it still goes
into the stomach and still messes him up
but I thought that was a brilliant
tactic to just coat your mouth and wax I
wish I could do something like that
[Music]
hmm hmm what some interesting flavors
going on there that's funny so it's
clear that you're a massive film and TV
buff I know that the Fraser obsession
runs deep and it's impossible to visit
your apartment these days without
catching a screening of into the
spider-verse pound-for-pound what do you
think is the best TV or film in regards
to food references oh it's got to be
chef that was one of the earliest
episodes I ever did was pasta hiya olio
from chef and then he came on my show
and we did chocolate lava cakes and I've
also done the Cubano sandwiches which
were unbelievable this moto marinated
pork but more than just all the
beautiful food in that movie it's about
the the togetherness and the uniting
power that food can have and it's a
movie that really loves food more than
most movies about food that big night
which is just like it's just food
paradise and then of course another
fascinating byproduct of your channels
it serves as a litmus test for some of
the most passionate cult fan bases on
the internet when you think back on the
videos that you've done do any standout
it seems like spongebob stuff always
floats to the top oh yeah
anything with spongebob in the title is
going to trend it's gonna skyrocket
because there's a gigantic fervent fan
base of which I am one I grew up
watching spongebob it's an old enough
show that I was like 11 when that show
came out I think this is where fandom
lives is in the food from fiction and
sometimes fandom especially when you're
doing these deep dive pop-culture
references I imagine that you sometimes
get fact-checked by nerds who are super
into this stuff have you ever been in
hot water with fans of a particular
movie or TV show
really from the fans I get more in hot
water with foodies people who you know
said are you gonna make that it's right
or you didn't do this right like people
have a lot to say about what I did wrong
and you know I try to make it as
instructional as possible but I'm
learning along with the audience like
this is a learning experience for both
of us
skinny habanero hot sauce does that mean
it's like low calories yeah yeah okay
I'm sorry I'm not trying to [ __ ] on your
brands it's just funny that's a skinny
habanero hot sauce all hot sauce is
pretty skinny so when I see hot ones
fans in the wild there are certain
questions that I can reasonably count on
you know people like what's the best
interview ever how is your butthole you
know those things I can count on so here
on this wing I think it's important to
hit you with some of the binging with
babish fa Q's which video is the most
difficult to make probably the second
episode ever which was tempeh no 14-hour
process right yeah Wow how did you know
that he always know all day all these
crazy little factoids well I just got
dizzy spell that was weird I shouldn't
have done that now I just know just I
already heard that when I said that yes
14 hours spent making tempeh no which is
I call it a big kinky lasagna it's like
10 different layers of pasta and
meatballs and eggs and cheese and sauce
and all kinds of good stuff is from big
night and I'm never gonna make it again
I promise
what's the most you've ever dropped
trying to get rare ingredients for an
expensive meal okay that's probably Red
Dead Redemption which is more recent I
dressed up like cowboy and I ordered
bear meat an actual genuine as they said
free-range bear meats but that episode
clocked in at at least $1,000 for the
costume and for the exotic meats and for
the tents and for the damage I did to my
car trying to drive a howdy a forward
and middle the woods
everybody always says it's the tastiest
one let's stay
well now you can know for sure hmm
there's good
so as we touched on you recreate dishes
from TV and movies and I know that that
comes from a genuine place of curiosity
well here I think that it's only right
that we do one that's inspired by a
spicy scene and we did some research and
there's one that I think that we can do
right here at this table and easy are
you familiar with the wake up Jews from
Back to the Future 3 is your 3 yes Back
to the Future 3 when Doc Brown he does
one shot passes out and then they whip
up some wakeup juice to wake him up
boom Andrew you always know these little
factoids well let's bring out the meson
plos oh my good oh is that your new
catchphrase huh huh or stealing it from
you oh good how about Chris with the
forearm strength to bring this out Wow
yeah how much it's not easy yeah that's
not a joke I can lift it I'm sitting
okay so what I think is easy about this
is it just involves like dumping stuff
into a glass right this has got to be
one of the easiest recreations so they
just kind of pour it in with reckless
abandon pickle juice and hot sauce at
the same time I remember correctly I
might be getting this wrong I'm sorry
and some nice hot sauce put the juice
there we go nice noises you guys getting
that little ASMR little poppy ASMR for
you there you go alright moonshine I
think was next
definitely poured in what looked to me
like Bloody Mary Mix but they obviously
didn't have that in eighteen 1885 oh
yeah I get that right give that a little
mixer if that looks right like that
looks like the right color and
consistency it's got stuff floating that
it doesn't look that bad it kind of
looks like a Lux Bloody Mary except with
no vodka Dez I may have a vodka oh wait
there's whiskey in there with us yeah we
got to stay true to the art after you
shot alright it'll cure what ails ya
it's definitely some wake up do ya see
what's going on here hit that wake up
I'm just gonna type the whole thing real
quick
the best part without a dad is the
classic ahh sauce
[Music]
before you made it your full-time career
making Homer Simpson's moon waffles I
know that you've worked as a graphic
artist you know sometimes when people
talk about taking that leap they always
give the advice as if it should be some
sort of reckless decision like you
should just say like [ __ ] it and jump
yeah I think for the vast majority of
people making ballsy butts measured
decisions is the way to go I didn't I
think about it all the time like I look
back I was reckless I quit my job I sold
all my [ __ ] I went to New York like had
four roommates tried to make you know
and I look back on it and obviously
things worked out pretty good but I look
back on that all the time and I'm like
that was [ __ ] stupid
you know like there's a lot of balls
that had to bounce my way in order for
me to just break even on it for it to
make sense when I moved here I sold my
car with no job I my car I got $2,000
for it and I used you know 1,500 of that
for one month's rent in some [ __ ] in
Park Slope and I think that if you
really believe in yourself and what
you're doing this is going to be a
moment where you're like this is a big
risk but this is the one that you know
could potentially change everything so
keep an eye out for it and you know be
cautious but be a little ballsy Pilon
crazy
the scallions is that does that
translate to the hots ones okay I get it
I get it
I took seven years of Spanish and that's
didn't absorb any of it hmm wow that's
good gee willikers what do I buy this
whatever you want Andrew I got you bro
well you already sent me a couple of
these bottles for Christmas stuff thank
you I got more of them for you today
thank you I Andrew have a little bit of
a surprise for you on this way all right
so we reached out to a few of our mutual
Internet friends and asked them if they
have any questions for you
Andrew ray all right so here is a new
segment that we're calling youtubers ask
other youtubers questions that's a good
guest come it's a segment that we're
calling questions from famous youtubers
that we both know so what we're going to
do is we are gonna show you on the
monitor up first we have hot ones alum
in front of the brand and he has a very
important question for you okay okay hey
all right real quick I want to know what
the number one most underrated kitchen
gadget is and the number one most
overrated
that's a great question Thank You Marcus
Brent Leigh the most underrated is a
cutting board a big fuck-off cutting
board like 24 by 18 like you know huge
big work surface that you can just own
and you know if you're chopping carrots
they're not rolling off and rolling
under the fridge and disappearing for
the rest of your life and the most
overrated kitchen gadget is the one that
does it all
or the one that does it all for you
because it never comes out as something
as good as something that you do
yourself some gadget they smack on to
make it chop onions it's never gonna
chop onions as well as you could or as
quickly as you good if you just practice
a little bit once you get good at it
you're gonna be way faster than some toy
that is trying to do it for you all
right up next we have our buddy Brad
Leone who was actually driving down the
highway pulled over on the truck stop
thought he could hit you with this one
thanks for that hey Sean Conan from a
Massachusetts truck stop got a question
for old babby while he says sweat in the
bean bag off eating those hot ones were
giving them yeah babby so with a you
know what your global reach using
YouTube what positive what positive
effects do you want to have on the
viewers huh my endgame is the same as
yours Brad which is to get people
cooking like you know he entertains as
he informs and that's like the best
thing you could possibly do on YouTube
is something that has utility something
that entertains is something that's that
inspires and that's exactly he doesn't
that's exactly what I want to do I want
to get people cooking all right one more
for you Andrew and this is from rhett
rhett and Link who is actually taking a
break from his vacation just into Polish
god it looks like he's got a beautiful
ocean behind him Andrew it's Rhett I
trust that you're not embarrassing
yourself yet my one piece of advice for
getting through this is to absorb the
energy of one wing to overcome the next
wing and by the time you make it to the
end you will have presumably absorbed
all the energy of all the wings that's
the key and the one question I have for
you is what is the one question that you
get asked most often that you hate
answering you're welcome good luck and
Godspeed that's a question from a guy
who's been famous for a long time like
that it's got to be what does babish
mean because I have answered it a
billion times and will a select will
answer here I'll play first I'll do it
I'll do it for you you hate answering it
you know what we know is from a niche
character from the West Wing you're
absolutely right how many episodes the
West Wing three eight [ __ ]
[Music]
hmm it's good mmm
I'm not giving you guys anything to go
don't own or except for that one why did
we do the first sauce recently did an
episode of the burger show with her
friend Alvin were you tempted to pass
muster as a line cook at his restaurant
the usual do you have a newfound respect
for line cooks having gone through that
experience no because I already had a
lot of respect the line cooks going
through that experience it takes a
certain kind of person to work in a
professional kitchen and I have nothing
but admiration for it because it eludes
me I I definitely do deflect the the
title of chef because I have not earned
it I am a home cook that has a camera
and knows how to shoot things very well
I will say that I'm a way better editor
than I am a cook so I make things look
good and I make it seem like it's easy
but I'm not a chef I don't deserve that
side
[Music]
next up we got Trinidad scorpion okay
that's the first one that's got a little
bit to it
that's fun all right I'm so dreading the
bomb oh my god well don't get ahead of
yourself okay sir don't know how you
don't psych yourself we have other stuff
to contend with here we go so I don't
think I'm being off-base when I say
you're a man who enjoys the finer things
in life I know that you're at your most
comfortable when you have a glass full
of the Glenfiddich or a gold Daytona on
your wrist or the rumble of a v8 engine
beneath your loins you're messing with
the bag what's in the bags no I have I
have a couple tricks here and remember
how I talked about Homer Simpson
lighting it and I were drinking a candle
well I have this candle from a sex shop
so you know it's good oh there we go I'm
just gonna get that melting because I
have every intention of pouring some wax
on my tongue to protect me from this
[ __ ] genius I've tried that before
my buddy in college like everybody like
everybody's roommate in college had a
bottle that kicking around in his fridge
and I touched some with a toothpick and
I I ran outside and like sprayed my
mouth with a hose I was young I was
being theatrical but it was it was it
was garbage hey welcome to my world I
like how you're like I was young as
being theatrical and then now you're
lighting a candle like you're like
you've grown I didn't say it changed
what's the best whiskey to call to a
bartender when they ask you what you
want you're old-fashioned because of how
widely available it is and because it's
it makes great cocktails but I do sip it
on its own angels Envy is one of my
favorites very complex but simple and
sweets it's a great American whiskey and
I absolutely adore it both on its own
and at cocktails for sure yeah I'm ready
to move on but I want to protect my
tongue from this [ __ ] okay so
I'm gonna where'd my little spoon go can
I just have
so I'm going to do I'm going to take a
page out of Homer Simpson's book first I
might put a little bit on my skin like
I've been a bad boy see what that feels
like okay I mean I feel disciplined and
this is taking a turn yeah you guys said
you want to try new things that's what
I'm here for
I like this cuz you know you always do
dishes from TV and film that's my bird
[Music]
all right so wax to coat the throat okay
all right who happens this is cheating
are people gonna call me out for you
it's honestly it's just never happened
I also just swallowed it like it's gone
so and it might not help you I don't
think it's going you know just drinking
wax out of this sex candle and then
eating the bob chicken wing you know
like if somebody's in the comments right
now be like that's cheating like he'll
Jean you're making it sound weird when
you say it like that
[Music]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah it's gross tastes
bad
it's not your book you read more proper
about yep mm-hmm
[Music]
[ __ ] the bum that's vile ah bringing
back memories
yeah of college and they're trying to
impress my friends will die just hiccup
I haven't hiccup in like seven years
from I'm hiccuping I swear I haven't
hiccup in like 70
it's magical for me are you crying
listen I'm not immune to it you know I'm
just didn't you're battling through that
is so excited that's so exciting for me
I picked up hiccups and so long this is
so cool I mean I'm not in control of it
it's so exciting
anyway well speaking of exciting you
know I think one of your most underrated
projects in my opinion is bedtime with
babish yeah where you would use your
calming soothing voice man you would
just read stories from public domain and
help put people to sleep oh you make me
feel so much better about myself
something happen oh no you touch your
eyes no but can I get a napkin I did I
caught some sauce in the eyes Oh No
let's take five minute break yeah oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] man Oh mouth feels like
it's swelling up Oh
who has my EpiPen I'm kidding
I think Dom do we have any more
[Music]
so now you want me to read bedtime
stories or some [ __ ] so I've pulled a
passage from The Velveteen Rabbit and we
have an ASMR mic Wow okay bedtime with
babish I'm a professional I could do
this sorry good evening and welcome to
bedtime with babish this evening upon
hot ones I'll be reading a passage from
The Velveteen Rabbit by Hans Logan
stockin there once was a Velveteen
Rabbit and in the beginning he was
really splendid his coat was spotted
brown and whites
he had real thread whiskers and his ears
were lined with pink sateen there were
other things in the stocking nuts and
oranges and a toy engine and chocolate
almonds and a clockwork Mouse and then
there was a great wrestling of tissue
paper and unwrapping of parcels and in
the excitement of looking at all the new
presents The Velveteen Rabbit was
forgotten
all right next up you ready for this
yeah the chocolate plague you barrel on
pucker button like a bunker but pepper
company that's fun so you have a very
close distinctly YouTube connection with
your fans and there are millions stupid
articles out there about like how to
build a YouTube audience with like
optimizing analytics and SEO keywords or
whatever do you have any real practical
advice when it comes to how to build an
energized of loyal fan base sorry I feel
like you get carpal arch on burps here
you can just do what you want
mmm what ah I feel like um the advice so
many people come up and ask you know
like how do I grow my channel brands
come and ask you know how do we grow our
channel and the advice that I want to
give but never do is you need to make
something really [ __ ] good especially
nowadays the world is so cluttered with
so much content and it's amazing
anybody can reach millions of people
with their cell phone if they do and say
the right thing but that's the key you
got to do and say the right thing and
that could mean the right thing for the
audience so that could mean the right
thing for yourself
I hope the mic picked up that weird body
sounds you're that uh
come on give me a proper dad belong a
Shan like dad there we go Shan like that
how [ __ ] my stomach hurts more in my
mouth honestly that's actually a worse
place to be I've been there I got I got
a eye rash my lips are on fire like I
would rather be completely smoked out in
the face than have my stomach doing
backflips yeah okay all right here we go
Cheers
[Music]
all right Andrew ray here we are at the
end of our spicy chicken wing journey
long overdue if you ask me and I think
it's been so special that we should
immortalize it forever and ever
how do you suggest we do that Sean what
we talked about it beforehand we did but
now is the moment of truth
there is no turning back are you ready
to do this already I'm so happy that I
was able to finish the wings honestly
let's do this come on ok or Randy over
and legal can you look into this camera
or this camera and say we are not
responsible or liable for anything that
happens here dear Randy over at legal
hey how are you
my name is binging with babish I do not
hold you responsible for any horrible
infection I can't right now for getting
tattooed amidst these wings and I don't
hold you responsible for anything really
you can do whatever you want to me right
now all right let's bring in Chris from
blackfish tattoo it's about to go down
here's the theater that you're why this
is happening you lean a little closer
[Music]
this ain't my first rodeo
Oh Papa the bomb is sadistic that stuff
just wants to hurt it's like a it's like
a mac-10 or pornography there's no
artistic value to it I have to cough
really bad what go ahead
[Music]
holy [ __ ] time flies near you having fun
here have some have some of the real
stuff I'll chase it there you go yeah
chase that milk whiskey like men do as
men do listen it does this [ __ ] have a
name you get to name the chicken all
right the chicken's name is drew I like
that
all right drew the chicken from here on
out you hear that Chris Oh what are you
guys doing this weekend any plans so
thin it's gonna blend him with like all
right so now we're done here goes oh
it's perfect
oh my god look at the lines on that so
thin look at this I can make it squawk
and it is a thing of beauty and look at
you Andrew pulling out all the stops and
now there's nothing left to do but roll
out the red carpet for you my friend
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
me hey guys my name is Andrew Ray I make
a channel called binging with babish and
my new cookbook drops October 22nd you
can check it out at binging with babish
comm slash cookbook you can pre-order it
there yeah that's it thank you so much
for having me
very thank you so much you know
something bad oh it's fine this is gonna
wash off in a few days right hey what's
going on hot ones fans this is Sean
Evans checking in to say thank you so
much for watching today's episode and if
you're gonna be in Chicago this weekend
good news will be there two hot ones is
showing up big at complex concha cago
doing a live episode with juice world
and then all weekend long in the first
movies own sling and wings sling and
sauces sling and merch
don't miss it July 20th and 21st in
Chicago we'll see you there
[Music]